the very first character that we come
across in eldon ring is our trusty mount
the spectral steed torrent throughout
the game torrent is our one constant
companion almost always just a whistle
away obviously this is impactful because
it opens up one of eldon ring's central
new innovations mounted gameplay and
quick traversal through the new open
world system but torrent also highlights
a new story element the fact that we
have a companion who is always with us
melano serves a similar role but we can
only interact with her at certain times
and at others she fully leaves us
all throughout our journey torrent is
there but we get very little information
about who or what torrent is besides a
ghost horse with demon horns so in this
video i want to explore the lore and
everything we can learn about torrent
the spectral steed
as i said torrent is the first real
character we interact with and paying
close attention to this opening cutscene
will begin to reveal some deeper truths
in it we see tauren approach us and
sniff us and melano speaks in direct
response to his snorts
don't worry torrent
fortune is on his side
we found him here after all
one of his kind is sure to seek
the elden ring
even if it does violate the golden order
we see here that torrent has expressed
some idea or emotion likely some form of
concern that we are seemingly dead or at
the least unlucky as we look at more
evidence we will see that this is just
the start of torrent displaying
preference and some kind of set of his
own motives in this opening it seems
that he is aligned with melano in the
hope that we as tarnished will be able
to seek the elden ring and even violate
the golden order
the next display of tauren's will comes
in our next meeting with melina when she
introduces herself to us melano offers
us an accord and pairs us up with
torrent in doing so she says i bequeath
to you this ring
use it
to traverse great distances
it will summon a spectral steed
named torrent
torrent has chosen you
treat him with respect
here we see melano offer us an accord or
contract but it is important to note
that torrent wasn't simply a tool given
to us as part of that contract melanoma
says that torrent chose us that the
horse made an active decision in favor
of us and we hear this again the next
time we see melana where she says
forgive me
i've been
testing you
to see whether or not grace truly does
guide you
and
whether you are fit to face the
challenge that entails
it seems my worries were unfounded
torrent had your measure from the very
start
whereas i merely pretended
only after this does melania take us to
the roundtable hold so melina was unsure
about us and whether or not we were
actually being guided by grace which is
fair since most other tarnished in the
lands between have lost the ability to
see the grace's guidance
but unlike melano torrent had picked us
right from the start and maybe dorant
doesn't have a complex mind where he is
wary enough to test us in this way but
in any case he knew we were the real
deal and chose us as such in being a
companion of melana and aiding us on our
journey to ostensibly help her it seems
that torrent is choosing what will
progress the plan melina has in mind
but to learn more about the background
of torrent and his potential motivations
there is another character we have to
look at the only other character in the
game that explicitly mentions torrent
and who happens to be theorized as
having quite a range of possible
connections with melano this character
is ronnie the witch or as she first
appears to us renault after we first
receive torrent from melana we can
return to the church of ella and ronnie
will appear using the name rena and if
we attack her she confirms what we have
previously heard tauren tat quite the
ruffian chosen here again is the idea
that torrent made a decision and chose
us further showing some kind of will and
intent on his part if we actually speak
to ronnie renna she reveals some more
torrent related info i'd heard tell of a
tarnished hurtling about atop a spectral
steed
and upon looking into the matter
the talk isomize is of thee
thou art possessed to the power no
to call forth a spectral steed named
torrent
ah
as i had hoped
i was entrusted this for thee
by torrent's former master
there's a belf calling forth spirits
summon them with it
from ash and return to the urgery
the spirits will obey thine command but
briefly
as they recall battles past
now it is thine
to do with as thou wishest
through some acquaintance with torrent's
former master ronnie is aware of the
spectral steed to the point where she
recognizes him when just hearing some
gossip about a creature like him a
spectral horse that can pop in and out
of existence this dialogue also opens up
a can of worms about tauren's history
and identity the item ronnie gives us
the spirit calling bell tells us a
little about spirits in general saying a
bell capable of summoning various
spirits from ashen remains spirits can
only be summoned in the vicinity of a
rebirth monument so if tauren is a
spirit then his summoning may have some
connection with ashen remains but we
know he isn't subject to the same
restrictions as the other ashen spirits
so this reasoning probably won't lead us
much farther another aspect we learned
from ronnie is that she knew toran's
former master and she knew this master
well enough to be entrusted with the
responsibility of giving the spirit
calling tool to whomever torrent chose
again we see action happening premised
on the fact that torrent is an active
agent but unfortunately there does not
seem to be any conclusive evidence about
who or what this former master was there
are a few potential theories on who it
could be first is the snowy crone who we
learn about from the snow witch set
whose hat reads which is pointed hat
brigid and frozen through of a style
associated with practitioners of
heretical sorcery strengthens cold
sorcery once worn by the snowy crone who
the young ronnie encountered deep in the
woods
she was a witch and well versed in cold
sorceries it is said that the doll that
houses ronnie's soul was modeled after
her that old witch was ronnie's secret
mentor
for a recap ronnie is the daughter of
ranala and ratagan and was or is an
empyrean which is someone who has the
potential to be the next god after
america ronnie wasn't about that life so
she killed her body on the night of the
black knives and put her soul into the
doll we see her in this doll is wearing
the snow witch set that was worn by
ronnie's old mentor the snowy crone and
it is modeled after her the set is found
in rena's rise so perhaps rena was the
name of the snowy crone
this theory could be supported by the
fact that it seems that ronnie had a
close relationship with torrent when we
meet ronnie for the second time she
almost immediately mentions torrent
saying
oh
again we cross paths
i believe i said my name was rena when
last we met
it pleases me to see torrent hail and
hearty
and towards the end half of her quest
ronnie again remarks on torrent
my thanks for thy sterling efforts
a strange gift
perhaps but a rare sort such as thee
would welcome it i'm sure
i am certain now
fate steered us to our first encounter i
must thank torrent too for his part
again we see torrent being treated with
agency ronnie's saying how she must
thank him for his part in helping us
help her and if ronnie has this
significant of a relationship with
torrent it stands to reason that she was
around him to some degree when he was in
the charge of his former master if that
master was ronnie's mentor that would
give them ample opportunity to spend
time together
another candidate for this old master is
a bit more obscure it's a theory i'd
heard about first on the elden ring
discord by a user jc rex which is
similar to what we've stated so far but
goes on to say that ronnie's mentor and
tauren's former master is not rena but
one called chilona the name chilona or
kilona or kelowna i don't know how to
pronounce it comes from a rise present
on the moonlight altar plateau this rise
has the player find three gargantuan
turtle or tortoise aberrations as its
puzzle which makes sense when you learn
that chelonoidis or calenoidus is the
name for a genus of tortoises the name
comes from the ancient greek word tolone
or chalone or colon or chalone or clone
i don't know which means tortoise the
crux of this theory is the fact that
chilona's rise is where we find ronnie's
darkmoon sorcery it reads the moon was
encountered by a young ronnie led by the
hand of her mother ranala what she
beheld was cold dark and veiled in a
cult mystery
while it does reference ranala the
placement of the spell so intimate to
ronnie here in this rise does give
grounds for a strong connection between
ronnie and chanola
also supporting this theory is the
presence of the wraith callers near the
rise these are forearm beings with pale
skin not completely unlike the forearm
doll that ronnie inhabits they also
wield the wraith calling belle whose
description reads ring bell using fp to
summon prowling rates this can be done
multiple times in a row wraiths are said
to be the vengeful spirits of those who
died when cursed this has obvious
parallels to the spirit calling bell
which ronnie gives us in our first
meeting this one just summons wraiths
instead of ashen spirits perhaps these
are both a kind of being different yet
similar to the kind of spirit torrent is
there's also one more piece of
compelling evidence here that is the
fact that wraith callers occasionally
ride horses themselves we can find an
example of this in lyrnia and it's hard
for me to not concede that this horse
does bear a bit of similarity to torrent
with its distinct jump though to be fair
there really aren't many other horses in
general around so maybe it's a reach but
maybe the fact that there aren't that
many horses means we should take a
second look at the connections between
the horses that do exist though i'll be
spending plenty of time comparing
similarities of horse-like beans later
on in this video i'll conclude this
section about torrent's potential former
master by just mentioning a final
candidacy there is a lot of lore we
don't know about ronnie and even more
that we don't know about melana because
of this and the fact that these are two
of the most unique characters in the
game who happen to bear a share of
similarities to each other there are
tons of theories about their potential
linkage are ronnie and melana two parts
of one bean is melanorani do they share
some other connection
all this to say maybe melana is torren's
former master she is the one who gives
us his whistle after all and she's the
only person other than ronnie to mention
torrent by name and remember how ronnie
remarked that she had to thank torrent
too i must thank torrent too well listen
to this bit of dialogue from melania
we're almost there
the flame of ruin lies just ahead
i'm glad it was you i traveled with
i must tender my thanks to torrent too
thank you
torrent
please continue to lend your aid
till the end
this is another point of agency for
torrent but it's also nearly the exact
same thing as what ronnie said except
molina actually explicitly says her
thanks to torrent is this evidence that
ronnie and melana are the same being i
don't know does this mean that melana is
torn's former master
maybe but it's still not conclusive
melanos surely knew torrent well but it
seems we have hit a dead end when it
comes to determine the specifics of
these relationships unless someone has a
really convincing piece of evidence to
establish what ronnie and melana are to
each other or who ronnie's mentor for
sure was
so now that we've explored these avenues
of torrance history there is one more
place we must turn to to learn what
torrent truly is we must look below the
sofa river i don't actually know he
pronounced ziophra editing mad chiming
in here to say that it is chauffeur
river according to my irish friend the
ancestral followers and most of all to
the regal ancestor
this area is one of the only in the game
where the erd tree is not present we
know that this separation is significant
because the regal ancestor's remembrance
reads ancestral spirits exist as a
phenomenon beyond the purview of the
urgery life spreads from death as it
does from birth such is the way of the
living
here we get insight into how these
spirits are a unique phenomenon of life
that exists independently from the
urgery and likely the whole golden order
and greater will this could provide some
idea of what kind of being torn is as we
know he is a spirit of some kind but
seemingly distinct from other spirits
like ashen spirits and wraiths there is
also the great horned headband of the
ancestral followers not many things in
game really look like tauren's horns but
these come pretty close hinting at some
connection and if we really want to see
some equestrian similarities we need to
look at my favorite boss in the game the
regal ancestor
yes it isn't a mechanically complex
fight but the mood and arena and
soundtrack are all just so encapturing
to me i love it but onto the point of
the video this boss is immediately
similar to torrent by being both an
ungulate and a spirit being and what
really sells the story is the fact that
the ancestor has a triple jump which
looks exactly like an evolved version of
our torrance double jump it even has the
same blue platform animation and sound
which really makes it hard to say that
there isn't a connection here and here i
want to note that while i do think i
made this connection myself i'm not sure
how much i'm discerning just throughout
this whole process as a silo versus
through my interactions with discord and
reddit so i just want to shout out the
elden ring discord servers and the
reddit as potentially great places for
discussion i'll link to them in the
description including one particularly
insightful reddit post from a user
crayola clock
so torrent is likely some kind of
ancestor spirit or spirit like them
maybe he would become something like the
regal ancestor with age eventually
learning how to take his double jump to
the next level reading the description
for the ancestral spirit's horn provides
more context a number of new growths
spud from the antler-like horns of the
fallen king each glowing with light thus
does new life grow from death and from
death one obtains power
so the ancestral spirits are all about
the cycle of life and death and they
seem to exist in some interesting space
partially dead and partially alive which
fits with the body of the boss being
some sort of spirit imbued carcass
now we have most of the information on
torrent laid out well all that and the
fact that he likes raisins we really
don't have definite conclusions to paul
but some speculation can let us say
something torn is likely a spirit like
the ancestrals maybe somewhere on their
plane of existence is where he resides
in between summons by us
and i've somehow managed to go this
whole video without reading the
description for his whistle so i need to
point out that it says a delicate
goldwork ring can be used as a finger
whistle sound the whistle to summon and
ride torrent the spectral steed upon his
death the spectral steed can be summoned
again but doing so drains the flask of
crimson tears now this could be an
overlook of translation but it says
death
so it's not that torrent just disappears
when he takes enough damage but he is
dying in a way and can come back all the
same this reads to me to fit with the
ancestral spirits and how they occupy a
murky space between life and death
i don't think there's anything more
concrete to say about torrent whose old
master is seems to be up to preference
of theory you can let me know in the
comments which one seems most plausible
to you or if you have another
alternative
when it comes to the story of torrent we
have said what we can he made active
choices about us and helping us on our
path perhaps being a spirit beyond the
earth tree torrent could see the issues
with your tree and the golden order and
assisted us with the hope of ending the
current order and replacing it with
something different maybe he just wants
everything to live outside of the order
somewhat similar to the ancestral
spirits and the underground followers or
if he has an affinity for ronnie maybe
that means he was aiming for something
like her ending we can't say for certain
but it seems clear that he has some sort
of goal against the order or general
setup he's helping us take things down
basically and i really think it would
have been nice to get a bit more of
development on torrent both as a
character since he does seem to be more
than a mindless horse floor-wise but
also in gameplay having torrent progress
with us somehow since we go through the
whole game with him would have really
provided another avenue for reward for
the player and it could have made
gameplay more fun
have some slight armor adjustments for
torrent maybe some skill developments
like the third jump or just more health
or more speed or more ability to do
different attacks while on horseback
this would have kept torn as a more
relevant part of the game all the way
through especially in something like the
last boss fight which really seems like
it would have been a perfect fit for him
to be in with us the giant open area to
run around with torrent end and i saw
another comment about how he would be a
good fit in the large open arena of the
ancestor spirit and the regal ancestor
as well those fights could have
benefited from running around with
torrent 2 and it would have painted a
nice kind of dichotomous picture without
any sort of progression for torrent in
this heavily progression-based rpg it
seems like a missed opportunity so we
have the setup for torrent to be a bit
more than just a means to an end of
faster traversal and open world
exploration but it just wasn't followed
through
obviously i have my qualms but
nonetheless torrent did prove to be more
than originally meets the eye and i
really like how he is an avenue to learn
more about quite a few aspects of the
game especially the ancestor spirits
some of my favorite character ideas in
the lands between
with nothing much more to say about the
lore of torrent i hope you enjoyed the
video if you did make sure to subscribe
for more lore and i also have a twitter
link in the description so feel free to
follow that too leave your comments and
thoughts about the story and lore of
torrent and thanks for watching bye